en las inmediaciones de este puesto de
control enjambra en el norte de la
cisjordania ocupada tuvo lugar el ataque
mortal dos mujeres israelíes murieron la
tercera su madre resultó gravemente
herida el ataque se produce tras los
ataques israelíes del jueves por la
noche en gaza y en el sur del Líbano los
objetivos de estos ataques nocturnos
según el ejército israelí fueron varios
túneles e infraestructuras
pertenecientes a jamás una respuesta a
la salva de cohetes lanzados desde la
franja de gaza unas horas antes según el
estado hebreo la gran mayoría de ellos
fueron interceptados por su cúpula de
hierro el repentino aumento de las
tensiones se remonta el miércoles en
pleno ramadán la policía israelí
irrumpió en la mesita de Alexa en
Jerusalén el tercer lugar más sagrado
del islam todo ello para desalojar a los
palestinos que se habían atrincherado en
su interior al día siguiente jueves día
de la Pascua judía se lanzaron unos 30
cohetes desde el sur del Líbano hacia
Israel el viernes muchos palestinos
manifiestan su rabia en el interior de
la mezquita de alaxa antes de la tercera
oración del viernes derramadán a pesar
de los crecientes llamamientos a la
moderación de la comunidad internacional
Benjamín netanyahu prometió responder a
toda agresión del bando enemigo el
movimiento islamista jamás por su parte
ha hecho un llamamiento a la unión de
todas las facciones palestinas